hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the hostile eyes alright need
to get out of here I've got a Power
Stone which is just phenomenal I don't
know why I need it oh now I got to go
through this hole pray not go let me
through
for some reason that's fantastic
right way to start with failure up yep
there we go we're gonna go through this
again jump and then fall and then grab
and then go back up just try it over and
over again and oh no what do you know
what they don't let me through
come on now this is the worst design
thing ever really okay get back on the
ladder inside again Oh nope not gonna
happen this time
maybe look downward angle when I go in I
mean my head is too high maybe my head
is just too fat
press Crouch while I do a jump at the
end nope I'm gonna let me through come
on now don't be like that up [ __ ] me
then right [ __ ] me in my attempts to
grab the ladder cuz I'm a giant dick
right that's the only answer oh boy it's
gonna take forever again this takes
longer and longer each time I come at
this ladder seriously no joke is just
bull
I mean I'm I originally went out at the
beginning of this let's play of this
custom story I love the my guy who made
this but seriously it's like the
beginning is all he played tested he
only played tested the beginning areas
and then the end he just threw together
in a few days I mean I was okay with him
being bad English and all that but this
is inexcusable there's no way that you
could play test your game in go up to
this point be like oh this is a problem
maybe I should fix it crashing not
crouching just what I do not crouching
this is my whole episode just me trying
to get in this [ __ ] hold and I'm
gonna be pissed
ah there we go I crouch jump in
[ __ ] just a giant Sun and stop
whistling in my ears shut up Billy Mays
whistling am I really getting annoying
it's like revolving around my head in my
speakers very annoying maybe I'm just
getting annoyed at things in this game
that's the understatement of the century
right there I I feel like an idiot to
saying that of course I'm getting
annoyed a thing to do this game this
game are annoying don't let me through
hope there we go okay now ah
this door is open not that I needed it
to be but it is why is this door closed
whoa
all right finally finally I can make
some progress on this stupid generator
now we go now we ride into the darkness
again because they once again I don't
have any oil but nothing I can do about
that I've been living with that for
about three episodes now so seriously
how do you not play test your game and
realize oh wait a minute
I don't have any oil to give my players
strength here yep there we go
and now that that's on do I put them in
here or there I think I put him there
yeah in there
one three what it's right don't tell me
that oh I got to put them in order
Oh Cassie do three huzzah all that for a
free dinner four episodes just to get
this generator started I am a douche
lovely oh this room is rather Freddie
now that I can see it who like that need
that something
now why is that there why is that that
way that it is okay maybe the middle
door downstairs open now this is this
this custom story this this custom story
ah swell I do declare it is a rather of
tubes and yeah here we go oh boy into a
room of darkness and level change level
change seriously I wonder if there's
like orb that I'm carrying in my back my
pack is just like some Easter Egg or
something
hello big door big door oh whoa what
holy crap
that's awesome all right I take back
whatever I said about this guy that is
amazing
that is incredible level design that is
incredible this must be like the last
level or something that is insane look
at that [ __ ]
I've got a bunch of stations here no oil
this chair does not fit Oh sorbets of
chairs all right jack you were chosen by
me let me look around to see if there's
anything of worth not housing so I got
the most valuable thing in here I mean
man look at that thing
mark okay nothing over there and I'm
there and I Jam this up junk junk junk
no John no okay there's a door
the door here no but
um come back your chair would you go
yeah come with me
back here which I can see I wish I could
see oh it's just one of those no big
deal
alright there's nothing anything over
here railing nothing to click
am I missing something I've got to be
missing something so I have a journal or
something wait I already did that stupid
momento we got a huge door with the
thingy but I don't even see a button or
a receptacle I see nothing
I see nothing is because I can't see
nothing what is that I can't see I can't
see I want to see I want to see so bad
what the hell I'm doing oh it's just a
door to the tower and it's not having
oil business is just [ __ ] tabulous
League terrible I looked around I didn't
I'm looking at every computer see
anything different anything interesting
see anything
huh nothing in these things I'll check
it out of the way they're in there it's
really bad designed to make those open
the same way but whatever okay um
there's no way to get out either there's
nothing
come button on that jewelry either all
right I'll go look at every one of these
again
whoa oh that's a chair never mind got
excited for nothing looking at all of
them see anything interesting taking
this one step at a time big TV screen
static electricity willing to go open
those some reason all right I'll go
around it once again very efficient very
efficient kind maybe I'll throw this in
and one of them ha broke your [ __ ] broke
it ha well it's pretty to look at but
starting to hate you again mr. designer
here starting to hate you
Cory tried shoving a chair into there
and nothing happened to didn't break
would let me try again
maybe maybe one of the metal chairs I
don't know seems like the only thing
that's possibly be on the right path
it doesn't even do anything literally
nothing shove myself in there touch it
shove it in there get in there real good
nice and tight right no pauses it up
all right whatever fine fine
golly I hate being lost touch this can I
can't touch that ah pound what if I
throw something in there or what if I
put oh there's ah there's other things
in those and that was not obvious ha
yeah
boy that was not obvious but okay
whatever how we do it what do we do
park is a place is a third to blow leave
epically
now this place is gigantic look at this
I didn't even know amnesia could make a
level this big I didn't know the game
engine could handle it
look at that [ __ ] unless that's like
some skybox
yeah it's got falling box and everything
again the technology despair
the beginning in that
okay Oh
they either
not where
okay
you moving forward
ah
oh yeah
ah it's at the end I still haven't
beaten see man
interesting
ah whoa
I am confused what is going on oh hello
Dell I like an air raid
come on door don't be screwin with me
alright then it does sound like an air
raid Wow whoa way too much camera shake
oh holy crap
is this the end hang on guys I want to
keep the end in one episode I always do
but if it's gonna take a while but I
want to say I'm gonna cut it here it's
only a little bit short so thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part bye bye